hi everyone I'm Kelsey and welcome to my
Cafe do you like coffee first of all
yeah I love I love coffee I try to have
some coffee once a day at least what's
like your milk preference uh just like
whole milk or cream do you like it hot
or cold I do both do you drink like
whole milk plant-based milk I don't
drink milk that often but I go
plant-based do you like to make coffee
or like do you like to like go hang out
with friends or like just like pick up
coffee to go I feel like I've ruined
many a coffee shop with like coffee
meetings or like work things yes
I know it's one out of five but like you
know I hope I put a smile on their face
regardless